see the last girl that i was seeing like
seriously
she was very heavily christian
and i'm not
anymore like i grew up but i'm really
not religious anymore and um
it was interesting because
when we were like together she was like
oh i don't know if this is correct i
don't know if this is right i think you
know
you should become a christian and i was
like no that's not gonna happen
um
she was like well i don't know if this
is right and i'm like
well look
we're in this we love each other like
what's the problem and she was like i
have to go and speak to my pastor right
and so i was just like okay
um
i'm not happy with that but if that's
what you feel like you need to do and
then she came back and she was like yeah
i don't think we can be together
and i was like isn't that interesting i
said your that's a deposit must be your
man then
she was like what do you mean i said
because any man that can talk to you and
tell you not to be me must be a man i'm
clearly not him
do you know what i mean so i said go be
your man and she was like
oh it's not like that i said listen no
no no no no because if i went away and i
said oh i'm gonna go and talk to
serena yeah and i came back from talking
to serena and i was at babe i don't
think we could be together who the [ __ ]
is that [ __ ]
i have never thought of that and i'm
like that must be your guy
and a lot of women like they idolize the
pastors in these churches you know what
i mean like
like they idolize the pastors so the
pastors have so much power like he's the
closest one to god of everyone right
exactly do you think that's why i think
it's completely different man i'll be
honest i think it's more
i think
i think a big reason why pastors today
are idolized a lot
by
single women is because
he tells them that god is going to bring
them my husband
so all they have to do is wait
and if anybody knows anything about life
you can't just sit in your ass waiting
for things to come to you right so it
kind of removes the responsibility
of having to
uh either put yourself out there or make
the effort or put yourself in an
environment
where
someone can come to you
right
um and i also think part of the reason
like i said about
about uh you know
i like that i like the idea of god's the
most powerful man you know
um
but again i think it's more because
i just know a few older women who use
the whole oh but i've got jesus as
as an excuse not to feel
lonely
it's like you know if all their friends
have kids and they're married and stuff
and then she's the only one single just
like oh like what's happened she's like
nah i've got jesus right mm-hmm and the
thing is because it's like a religious
sentiment it's hard for anybody that
jesus said hugging you at nighttime
you're not gonna argue with that yeah
do you know what i mean but that's just
my thoughts don't you think it's them
arguing with themselves
yeah low key it's like
they they say i'm not about jesus but
just i feel like they're thrown at you
as you said because they know it's a
sensitive thing yeah they're not they
just throw it so
other people can't be like to them all
yeah because you can have jesus and
that's really my point yeah that's
really my point but the church sorry
i was gonna ask you the girl that like
broke it off with you because you
weren't christian were you hooking up
with her yeah to some degree yeah yeah
so like isn't that
like she go ask her pastor about that
i mean
that was that was
the point of contention yeah
that she like how old was she she's like
30 33 oh my gosh yeah
so it's like
that was a point of contention because
she felt guilty about it do you know
what i mean and i'm like
i feel guilty that very love
do we want you know what i mean yeah but
um yeah it was she had a stronger sense
i guess or a stronger feeling towards
you know the church and her religion and
stuff which is you know it's cool it's
just like a very interesting experience
for me to go through like oh [ __ ] like
jesus cop blocked me do you know what i
mean
what the [ __ ]
it's just like
wow never did i ever think i would ever
hear those words in my eyes
have you guys found do you think dating
girls in the church is better
like have you do you prefer girls that
are in church
i depend
i think it depends what you're looking
for
okay i
i think because i've dated a couple of
girls who are quite
uh heavily christian
and they're very
traditional
which
brings a lot of things which are really
nice yeah i agree if you're at a certain
stage in your life where
you know
um
i'm gonna say
they're
quite wifey material but if you're not
looking for a wife then it's not for you
at that point in your life i would say
at this point in time in these days and
times
generally churches
are no different from the streets
the same women that are in church on a
sunday were just in the club on the
saturday
well that's why i was asking because i
was thinking i've heard a common
complaint from men about dating in the
church is that they're for the streets
too and they thought they were going to
go to church to find a wife and they
just find like
a 304 in sheep's clothing you know like
yeah that's true no as i'm saying
there's a say i i think that the women
in the church are the same nowadays to
say because the women that yeah they're
in the club they're in the bars they're
doing the same things that we're doing
but
i guess they have that in their head
they have that safety net of oh but i'm
going to church and you know i do all
this church stuff it's like well you did
have sex with tyrone last night forgive
me
if it makes you feel better that you go
in church on sunday then so be it do you
know what i mean so
i don't
you know when you say so you know you
said that you know some guy said about
the girls that go to church for the
streets are they
how old are these women they're younger
women are they older women like well
i've heard a couple different things um
i've heard a lot of like single ma
single mothers go to the church and they
become like born again virgins basically
yeah i've in the church i was involved
in that
[Music]
it's like when you re-virginize
do they do they do an operation to put
your hymen back or like
it's like um
i mean it doesn't really make sense
okay it doesn't it's just basically like
where the girls
regret the guys they slept with before
and then they want to make the new guy
wait for marriage for the girl basically
um yeah and i've seen i've seen girls
that this like worked for actually like
like there were girls that um in my
church like from home i wouldn't say
they were like three of like super you
know but
yeah but i've also seen girls like still
single in their like mid-30s you know
because they're waiting
and you know what's so funny it's very
interesting you say that because
there's such a high concentration of
women in the church right
and there's not such a high
concentration of men in the church the
men that are in this church generally
are probably married
probably got probably god would be
really good men like probably good men
but so they get snapped up quite quick
by these women you know what i mean so
it's like
so then
what happens is it as i say in my
situation which is i've heard it a lot
of the time
um
the pastor will say obviously the man is
not in the church that you're seeing
because they have to go outside of the
church to get man because there's none
in the church generally so when you go
outside that means you're not getting a
church guy
they tell the pastor and the pastor says
oh he's not um of the same two people of
the same yoke or whatever the bible
verse is right you're not equally yoked
or whatever it was and so
the pastor
basically puts
you know a no and says no you can't do
that and it's like wow okay this is can
you imagine having like someone having
that much control over your life that
that happened to me that that with my
last boyfriend like i um because he
wasn't because okay when
i when i got baptized they like told me
because i grew up catholic and then i
like switched to a christian church
right and um
but then like they have to have you
re-baptized even though what i don't
know but
i was like okay
no well no i wasn't
no no but
i don't that's not real like yeah
but my last boyfriend wasn't um part of
the church but it was like one girl to
every three guys so i'm like what the
what else am i gonna do yeah like i'm
not trying to fight over the like five
beta guys here
that's the thing right
church guys no they're they're soft they
women find church guys quite softly yeah
would you say that's true
yeah yeah yeah like they're quite square
and soft that's what i've heard women
say no okay this is usually how i'm
gonna i'm gonna tell you church dynamics
there's usually like one or two guys
that aren't like a couple right but all
the girls want him like i'm not trying
to fight him like
over a guy with like 10 other girls that
are all lined up you know
so
uh and he knows he's got to pick it a
bunch yeah
like he's like whoa i could just swag
her into church
when i could just date someone not in
the church like that seems a lot easier
but then your pastor will say that's the
wrong thing too that's well that was the
thing i got a call it was like really
awkward this was such an awkward phone
conversation it wasn't from the pastors
from like another girl that i did like
bible study with at the time
and she like called me and was just like
well
he
he's not in the church and i'm like okay
so so what like what are you telling me
to do should i dump him
but no i didn't i just dated him anyway
but
oh there's that pressure though
no it made me not want to go anymore
yeah because it's like
awkward yeah
yeah you know
but that's the thing about this is the
difference catholics we mind our own
business okay
christians are all up in each other's
business right because they look at it
as like a community thing the catholics
we would just get our communion on
sunday see no evil like
i'll leave it for confession
i'll go and tell you know i'd go and
tell the bishop or whatever
but um
yeah like i think i feel like
church does keep women single like that
yeah when you can control
like
who you're seeing from who you're not
seeing even though knowing that there's
not a bunch of men in the church that
these women can actually choose from
like what's a woman supposed to do i
have a question for